Mẹ hai thăm một, hàng loạt của tôn hàng đã sĩnh xa tại nhiều tình thành trên khắp i Rand,
nhằm lên ăn cảnh vì bảo loạn và thị hiện sự hộ đối với chính quyền nhảnh nước cộng hoa hồi giáo i Rand.
Theo chuyển thông nhảnh nước, các cuộc sửa hàng đưa dễn xa đồng loạn với đông đảo người dân tham gia.
Chuy đó i Rand khi nhẹng số cuộc tụ tập nhỏ lệ phản đối khó khăn kinh tế, tuy nhiên dưới chức tế Rand cho rằng,
tó hoa đồng này đã chuyển hướng sẵn bạo lực, giòn sự khi động từ phía bên ngoài.
Trong đào của thế là tử Mỹ và y sửa, chính quyền đi Rand khẳng định vẫn cảm kênh dạy của các bạn địa kinh tế,
sau mẹ kiên quyết sự li càng vì gây mắt đầu định về phía Mỹ và y sửa,
tổng thống đơn trăm và tụ tưởng mấy cho mình đi tàn dào hù đánh nhiều lần công khai,
bây tổng hộ người biểu tình tế Rand, đồng thời cạnh báo sử dụng các bạn tham mạnh.
Các pháp biểu này bị tế Rand chỉ chết là cám thiện và công việc đối bộ.
Thao của tụi này ngành diễn xa, sau khi lãnh tụi càng yên Rand,
ali thì mình này kêu gọi đoàn kết của ra, nhấn mạnh i văn sẽ không nhận bộ cho càng đồng phá hoài,
và tí tụi bảo vệ uống định đơn đưa.